[Music]
public finances are in much better shape
public depth is going down no member
state is now subject to the corrective
arm of the stability and growth pact or
excessive deficit procedure compared
with 24 member states in 2011 our shared
fiscal rules have played a positive role
in ensuring financial stability which is
precondition for sustained economic
growth and job creation the European
economy experienced seven years of
consecutive growth and is forecast to
continue expanding this year and next
and it is now greater economic
convergence among member states public
depth in some member states remains very
high fiscal policies have generally not
helped to smoothen the economic cycle
the reduction of economic imbalances has
slowed down while external depth remains
high and a current account surpluses
persist in some countries and we see a
reform fatigue setting in last but not
least our rules have become overly
complex and hard to explain so today we
are starting an open debate that will
give all interest for interested parties
a chance to view their views on ways to
strengthen the frameworks implementation
and effectiveness
the sustainability of public finances
remains key it may not sound exciting
but this is a bedrock on which we can
build everything else debt levels need
to be sustainable to create an
environment that is conducive to
investment and rose but it should also
take into account as a change economic
context with low growth low inflation
and low interest rates and law reform
momentum and to factor in to urgent
challenges to make Europe the first
climate neutral continent and the one
that is fit for the digital age
and we know that these will require
massive investments we had also mixed
results because of the complexity of our
rules we have to consider the fact that
complexity is also a form of
intelligence so it could be useful
complexity to have a flexible and
intelligible reaction to crisis but
complexity is also difficult to manage
and controversial so we have to work on
this
the targets of the review we are
launching are clearly very clear the
main one want to preserve stability
looking to high depth and macroeconomic
imbalances we are not changing our
treaties second relaunching growth to
avoid a sort of low for long low
inflation low interest rates low growth
for too many years and to avoid the fact
that only monetary policy is asked to
face this low for long situation I think
we need first ambition in this
discussion
second an extraordinary effort to bridge
differences because to to follow
differences brings us nowhere it is not
a technical exercise is something
dealing with jobs well-being protection
of our communities and so as Valdez was
saying we will have this public debate
with the effort to have a common vision
and avoid divisions
Avinashi seen in the start